what's going on guys we are back with
the man the myth the legend the
delightful Patton Oswalt you are a
pillar of the geek community a squat one
but a pillar no yeah our fans love you
we love you and they wanna when we said
that we were gonna have you on they
threw some questions at us so nice yeah
can i straw you up flattered yeah yeah a
little bit of a speed round from Twitter
here we go you've said before that
spider-man is your favorite superheroes
Jamie Rogers from Twitter says how do
you feel about spider-man coming to the
MCU and the recasting who would you cast
obviously I'm very happy that he's
coming to the MCU I would like them to
play with that whole universe I would
want the x-men in there all of it gotta
say I thought Andrew Garfield did a
great job so I do not have an opinion as
to I think they should have kept him I
thought that dude worked his ass off in
that role and also clearly loved it John
Appleton asks thoughts on new Star Wars
I don't have any thoughts because I have
not seen anything yet and I and it
drives me crazy when people write these
long think pieces I know they got a fill
space but it's like you need to wait to
have seen something George Lucas did
Star Wars and was humble enough to go
I'm gonna walk away from the table
they're comping my drinks they're
comping my hotel room I'm gonna let
someone else spin the wheel and so we
have a guy who could not be more excited
to be doing it just like Kirchner and
Marquand were when they did Empire and
return respectively they love making
movies so you know JJ loves to make
movies so that's that's what's giving me
hope if you haven't seen Patton's Star
Wars filibuster then you probably don't
have an internet connection yeah you're
everywhere on to check it out it's so
great if he holds the reality gem that
means he can jump from different
realities this will be our link from to
the Marvel Universe from the Star Wars
universe they do a thing on that show
where you do a couple of takes on the
script and the scripts are always funny
yes then they go we'll do a fun take do
whatever you want and so all they're
saying is you need to start a filibuster
and then Amy and Jon Glaser will cut you
off but then what I didn't know was all
the writers are under said just don't
yell cut and
simple amigos see how long he'll talk
you know there's a fight-or-flight
response
well apparently there's a third response
called the trivia dump where you just
yell every bit of comic and movie trivia
you have in your head out to prevent
from being fired yeah you combine Star
Wars with the marvel see exactly an
exactly mythology as well it trust me if
I had had more water in my mouth I would
have worked in the characters from
Reservoir Dogs I would have had Olivia
newton-john's character from Xanadu come
skiing in there I would have throat I
would have had all that what had the
baseball Furies from the Warriors show I
would have just kept going so uh epic um
80s lover says what is your dream movie
crossover so we just talked about a
little bit DC and Marvel Terminator and
Robocop inception and Freddy Krueger you
know what my dream crossover would be
huh think about this for a second in the
city of Zion and the matrix they've
defeated the matrix except that one tiny
computer virus from the early 80s
Skynet infects the matrix and the only
way that Zion can fight it is to not
only find the new neo but what they
realize is the new neo is hidden in
another bit of software lost matey's
OCPs Robocop software and then that's
your hole it's the Terminator bull dip
Terminator and Robocop fighting for
viral supremacy within the matrix and
the Smiths resurrect to try to fight
both of those off do it favor just
battle royale Patton please stop blowing
my mind they have to make a Robo neo
basically Wow that's awesome
okay um what do you think of the DC
movies going gritty while Marvel is more
lighthearted
listen there's nothing wrong with going
gritty if your source material is gritty
it's why the the Christopher Nolan
Batman movies are great it's why the TV
series arrow is great but if something
is bright and primary colored and
hopeful you got to embrace that that's
why you know one of the reasons that I
didn't think this the last two
spider-man movies um didn't work despite
I thought Andrews great work and those
was they went dark and gritty spider-man
is primary colors in the day
like that's why the Christopher Reeve
movie is so timeless the first one he is
absolutely positive he will you know
he's not all eating he's not dark he's
not self-important so and that would
give him and Batman something to fight
over but the way it looks right and
maybe I'm wrong but all that art they
just look brooding brooding meets
brooding meets brooding it looks like
three Goths hanging out in a candle
store that's what the new one looks like
and then the Aquaman thing he looks like
the he auditioned to be the lead singer
of Dera work in ER wanted to know what
do you think of the new Aquaman lay it
on us it looks like he wanted he
auditioned to replace Rob Zombie in his
band and Rob went yeah that's you look a
little too silly Aquaman
should be like a big funny like brawling
he should almost be like Quint in Jaws
you should just be this big brawling you
know like pirate captain ties yeah now
you've got a distinct possibility just
banging into each other
you could I'm just sick of here oh is
this my camera I'm sick of seeing
superheroes do they uh is this the only
pose they have is the weird Kubrick
stare like how about like the the the
Aquaman thing he should be like laughing
and I know when whenever they introduced
Green Lantern he's gonna it's me the
ring he's be going like this damn it
guys I'll stop with the brooding the
only one who gets to brood is Batman
that's the it only works if he's the one
brooding guy the head I'll be brooding
preach Patton damn it sorry no amen des
okay thank you
Jordan W wants to know are we going to
ever see a ratatouille sequel if we ever
see a ratatouille sequel I'm gonna be
the last person they tell it'll happen
because Brad Bird will get some amazing
inspiration unfortunately I'm friends
with him and he has about seven movies
lined up in his head that are so friggin
brilliant yeah that if we never see a
ratatouille - as a film fan I can only
be so upset because I'm gonna get to see
all his other amazing ideas lines out so
yeah and other stuff on and on yo @ DK
de Frank asks the best superhero movie
of this century Oh for the love of God
wait a minute
you know what spider-man - the one with
um dr. octopus that movie was brilliant
there are some really great deep smart
things going on in that movie so as far
as superhero movie that's been the best
one so far as far as comic book movie
the best one has been American Splendor
oh yeah yeah yeah but if you're just
doing pure superhero than spider-man
- and last question Chloe are Glen cloak
Clos uh you're just making that up that
you that sounds like something you'd
make up if I was a homicide detective in
asking you it so who are you tweeting
with like you know Chloe our Glenn cloak
cloak or clack old what would your dream
role to play be uh in terms of comic
books or any role any rope a great actor
if you haven't seen big fan and you
don't know like you're you're an
excellent actor so any role Arturo in uh
in geek love would be amazing just the
image of him like with his mask on
floating in the bottom of that tank but
preaching to people and they're all you
know they want a bit that just amazing
and is there a character um in comics
that you'd love to portray I would love
to own because he's kind of tubby but
but still flexible and he's trying to be
Harold would be the original Golden Age
Sandman Wesley Dodds and if DC would do
a movie like that not maybe not just
about the same in about the beginnings
of their world do a Deadwood style super
movie where you see Gotham metropolis
New York and there's you know people
talking about Thomas Wayne and you know
that the Daily Planet just so you're
seeing the roots of it but you're seeing
the
heroes like Sam man the Crimson Avenger
our man the Wildcat stuff like that oh
yeah that'd be really cool Wow
thank you for answering questions people
on Twitter you owe at Patton Oswalt a
big thank you oh thanks screen junkies
for bringing me out here oh heck yeah
that's all thing um I want to talk more
about the
second book you love movies and this is
about a time in your life were you that
was this is the time of my life where I
was basically stalking movies yes um it
was four years between 95 and 99 where I
basically saw at least two films a day
Wow a date at one point it got so bad I
mean the most that I saw that year I
think it was 1996 I saw 261 movies just
in theaters that's not counting on DVDs
on television and just immersed myself
in that world and then had to kind of
fight my way out of it because I was
becoming a screen junkie and if this
website hadn't existed that would have
been the title of this book to any movie
going experiences cut through I mean I
know you talk about a lot in here you
want to share one particular story with
I remember one you know this is a really
good lesson for me because it showed me
that sometimes you can be a little too
snobby and rarefied in your film tastes
me and a couple of comedian friends went
to see the replacement killers and they
show the trailer for wild things so
there's all this just bikini bikini
boobs boobs entry gall you know we're
all scoffing at it because it's a very
trashy trailer yeah it's a trashy
trailer for a brilliant film while
things is a brilliant one of the best
modern Noir is ever made in my opinion
but the trailer is so trashy and means
two teenagers sitting in front of us
turned to each other when it was done
and went yeah like and which was this
way of like oh yeah you're not in touch
with what movie goers want because you
just saw the reason that movie is going
to be successful right in front of us so
there was that nice little lesson of
like okay yeah screen junkies fans this
is a call to action go out there pick up
this book go to your retailers do it
online buy multiple copies patton oswalt
hi thanks for yeah you've been a super
cool dude thanks for being here and
thanks for having me I really appreciate
it oh yeah it's been fun talking with
you yeah thanks for answering
everybody's questions thank you for
watching the show I'm Hal Rudnick kept
me up my twitter hit him up on twitter
bye bye hey screen junkies would you
like a chance to sit ringside and a real
episode of movie fights click the link
below for info on how you can enter the
arena and watch the mayhem in person do
you have what it takes